Hello, hello.
We're going straight in.
No intro because we got... I guess we listened to Jeff.
Hello, everybody.
We're going straight in.
So we're going to listen to Jeff say whatever the fuck he wants to say.
Hello, guys.
I literally just got back from concert stuff, so I'm tired.
But I'm here to watch some more Summer Game Fest trailer...
Some more game trailer release.
Oh, God.
I need to turn this volume down.
He's way too fucking out.
I can't stop listening to games sometimes.
Sorry.
I'm just... I'm tired.
I know Jeff is a great guy.
He's a great guy.
I heard he's a great guy.
I'm just...
Guys, look.
I do not want to close any doors here.
I don't want to close any...
Look, he's Kojima's best friend.
Inzoy is a top selling...
Okay, to be fair, I feel like people only buy Inzoy...
Just for the character customization...
And then they don't fucking...
Then they uninstall it.
And then they uninstall the game.
It's literally just for the character customization...
And that's it.
I swear, I have not seen an actual gameplay...
From that game.
I feel like I have not seen real gameplay from it.
You might get some nominations at the end of the year.
We're not there yet.
But it is a monumental achievement...
Earning the highest...
Like, I don't even know what that game is about.
Like, other than the character customization.
Yeah, I was like, wait.
There's an actual gameplay in it?
So let me know...
How the sound is...
For Jeff...
It's just The Sims?
I've never seen any gameplay.
I swear to God.
I have not seen a single gameplay of this game.
He's very quiet.
All right, let me turn him up.
Isn't that a good thing?
And that's precisely why events like Summer Game Fest, our partner showcases happening all weekend long, and initiatives like the Steam Next Fest are so essential.
These events help remarkable games, big and small, find their audiences.
And hopefully, if you're watching this show, you'll discover your next favorite game.
All right.
So, in that spirit, let's kick things off with a game from an independent studio who is thinking very big.
In 2017, four developers broke away from AAA publishers to chart their own course.
He's a part of a small indie studio, right?
And what you're about to see is a powerful testament to what passion, freedom, and a small, dedicated team can achieve.
Let's take a look at our first new game announcement.
Oh, the first game is always... the first and last game is always the best ones, right?
Bloodborne?
Guys, if they did not announce it on State of Play, we're not getting it here.
Whoa.
Performed by Behemoth.
Whoa, wait.
Spiritual successor to Bloodborne?
What is this?
Mortal Shell?
What's Mortal Shell?
Is this heavy metal Bloodborne?
Bloodborne?
I'm a what?
A weapon?
A wizard?
This looks like fucking hardcore bloody...
This looks like...
Bloodborne rated R.
Yeah, edgy.
American Bloodborne.
You know what the...
This looks...
Wait.
Okay, I need to know.
Was this by an American studio?
This looks like...
Okay.
So you tell that Bloodborne is from a Japanese studio, right?
So like...
It feels like Bloodborne...
But what if it was created by an American studio?
There's something about it...
That just tells me that this was done in America.
I don't know.
This one...
There's a feeling.
It's like...
I don't know.
I think it's the edginess.
It...
Like...
It just feels...
More bloody.
Because like...
You guys know that like...
A lot of Japanese...
Studio games...
Oh, Mortal Shell.
Is Mortal Shell actually from an American studio?
Or was I wrong?
I never heard of Mortal Shell before.
Apparently it's Mortal Shell 2.
So there was...
It's a sequel.
But is it an American...
Oh, it's German.
Okay.
I was gonna think...
It's either...
It's either American or German.
I could tell...
Because it's that feeling.
That makes a lot more sense.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I was gonna say...
This is the reason why.
It's because like...
You guys didn't know?
A lot of like...
Games that were developed by...
Japanese studios...
Actually get heavily censored...
In...
Um...
Here's the first...
Oh, am I low?
Um...
It gets...
Really censored...
In Japanese releases.
So like...
Resident Evil is actually really...
Like...
In terms of goriness...
And blood...
It's actually...
Really censored...
In the Japanese release...
Uh...
For the game.
What the fuck?
Is this Fortnite?
Fortnite?
Did you see that goo guy?
The...
Is this Fortnite?
This...
Yeah, it was...
I saw the purple goo guy.
I was like...
Wait a minute.
Who the fuck is that guy?
I think I saw a Jonesy.
All right.
Right now, it is an honor to welcome...
To Summer Game Festival...
I didn't hear him say Fortnite.
I was too busy explaining about Resident Evil.
...project in just a few short weeks.
With each of his games...
He pushes the gaming medium...
In bold new directions...
And we are honored...
To have him with us...
For the first time...
I'm glad you're showing up...
This small indie game.
I know, right?
I can't believe...
The small indie studio...
From Epic...
Oh my god!
Kojumbo!
Is he gonna show...
Pokora?
His...
His Oshi?
Oh my god.
I...
Honestly, it'd be...
Pure cinema...
If he like...
Talks about like...
The VTuber addition to his game...
Journey Summer Game Fest.
It's great to have you here.
We are so excited for DS2.
So, let me ask you, Mr. Kojima...
You've worked for many years on this project...
He has to show his Oshi 2 that work.
What do you hope players take away...
From DS2 when they play it later this month?
Well, we hit the pandemic...
After we released DS1.
Everyone experienced the pandemic.
So, I wanted to show something new...
Connection...
After we face the pandemic.
So, I want everyone of you to think about that...
When you play this game.
How's the volume for the...
That's coming out later this month.
But right now, I know you've prepared a special...
The watch-a-lan.
Like, what they're talking about.
Is it okay, sound guy?
Let's take a look at this.
I don't know if sound...
If sound guy's already said anything.
It's a little low.
Alright, what is sound guy saying?
I could...
Oh, do a little bit more.
Alright, this is...
I'll update a little bit more.
Volume is good here.
Okay, sound guy.
I'll update a little bit more.
So, let me know if...
I should lower it then.
Actually, I could just...
Oops.
Welcome.
Hello.
What, is this Death Stranding?
What's this?
Yeah, where's Pecora?
Oh, it's because usually my mods talk in Discord.
But, like, since I have only one monitor...
I just wanted to talk in the chat.
Because I...
I...
I don't...
It's too much of a hassle.
So, you are near Vanna.
Mm-hmm.
Where the fuck is my VTuber?
What do you do?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Is Pecora really his Oshie if he's not gonna show her to the entire...
In the Summer Game Fest?
I'm a porter.
You think Jeff's gonna do anything about it?
Ha ha ha.
Jeff's gonna do nothing.
Come on, Kojumbo.
You know you want to.
So, thank you.
We're good for the day.
You know you want to.
Ha ha ha ha.
What is it?
So, you made it then.
Sorry.
Who's...
Which famous actor is he?
You really don't remember me.
Whoa.
Oh!
Workplace harassment.
Stop!
I'm calling HR.
Yeah, that is very unprofessional.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Neil and Lucy.
Well, that was a...
Luca Marinelli.
We saw our first clips of Neil and Lucy.
And we met them in the trailer back at South by Southwest.
But we got a little bit more of them here.
Tell us a little bit more about this clip.
Is he a famous actor?
In DS2.
It's a very important character.
I just realized Conan O'Brien was in Death Stranding 1.
I can't really say because there'll be spoilers.
So, I want to know, like, what other cameos is he going to have?
What other, like, American actors are going to be in this one?
Or famous actors?
Yeah, there's a lot of cameos in Death Stranding 2 Picoras.
And of course, by story...
Could Jumbo just add all Pecora?
JK is just all Pecora.
But this time, Neil will be like...
Oh my god, too!
Ha ha ha ha!
Uh, for DS2 this time.
And Cliff was a very popular character.
But I think...
We have to kind of, like, top that character.
So Luca Marinelli was a great actor, and I think...
Wait, what does Luca Marinelli do?
So I think you'll like this new character, Neil, too.
Yeah, he loves Hollywood.
The game's going to be out in 20 days, so I'm not going to give any spoilers.
Wait, in 20 days?
It's that soon?
But there is more to share, and...
Oh, he does Italian films?
...to learn more about the game, actually.
This Sunday, as part of Summer Game Fest, would you tune in to the DS2 live game premiere, where Hideo will be joined by many members of the cast.
He'll be sharing a new demo of the game, live gameplay demo.
That's actually really...
Yeah, I didn't realize it's that soon.
I feel like I have not seen enough gameplay.
This is not the last that you've seen of Neil this weekend.
Wait, wait, it's coming at...
I feel like I did not see much gameplay of this game, other than cameos.
If you enjoy, we'll join us Sunday, too.
Excellent.
All right, thank you so much.
Hideo Kojima, everyone.
Great to see you, Mr. Kojima.
Thank you.
The gameplay at Death Stranding.
All right.
That's Kojumbo for you.
Now, my co-host for Summer Game Fest.
She's along for the party.
A veteran games journalist on GameSpot and the co-host of the Friends Per Second podcast.
Please join me in welcoming the incredible Lucy James.
I'm so confused.
I didn't realize it's that soon, because I feel like I've seen nothing substantial in terms of gameplay.
Thanks, Jeff.
And hello, Summer Game Fest.
I am so excited to be here this year.
Thank you for having me.
Now, we are honored to reveal an exciting new project from Raw Power Games, a new team headquartered in Copenhagen, Denmark.
Here, you can engage in intense combat, fight for land, glory, and legacy, and lead massive armies into epic-scale battles as narrated by actor Tom Hardy.
Tom Hardy?
Venom?
What?
What do you mean, Tom Hardy?
Mad Max?
How many inches of Venom is in this game?
You know, like, Venom isn't even voice acted by Tom Hardy anymore, because, like, it's, like, too much for his voice.
He doesn't even actually voice act Venom.
No.
It's done by someone else.
I forgot his name.
Um.
I forgot his name, though.
Yeah, it's very straining to them.
He's, like, Hey, yeah!
Like, Like, that voice is fucking hurts your throat.
Go write your own.
What game is this?
Is this...
What?
Chronicles Medieval.
Oh, it's a game I'm not gonna play.
I'm sorry.
Like, it's...
It looks like an RPG game.
Yeah, I was gonna say, it looks like Kingdom Come.
It's time to hang on to the edge of tomorrow.
Sonic Racing Cross Worlds is a thrilling new entry in the legacy of racing action games with a Sonic franchise.
And I got it for like, Yeah!
Sonic Racing!
Brings other worlds and familiar faces to Sonic Racing, including surprise guest characters being revealed here at SGF.
Let's fucking go!
Finally a real game!
Let's go!
I like how people are cheering for it.
They're like, Yeah!
Sonic Racing!
We're so excited.
Oh,
shit.
Wait, that's not a car.
Who let this guy...
What the...
That's a...
Wait, that...
Oh, that's a famous Sonic game.
Wait, uh...
Hatsune Miku?
Hatsune...
What the fuck?
That's...
That's a...
Itchy pie!
Wait, what the...
What the fuck?
Oh my god!
Persona!
Let's go!
Finally a real racing...
What are these...
Okay, I...
What?
What are these cross-overs?
What is this game?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Death on arrival Mario Kart.
That's right.
A real competitor this year.
The game is safe.
Now.
Oh my god.
Look, it even has... I like how Sonic Racing Cross Worlds even has the word worlds in there.
They're like, yeah, Nintendo.
That's right.
That's right, Nintendo.
We have Hatsune Miku.
What do you have?
That's right.
You think your moo moo cow can beat Hatsune Miku?
You have cows.
We have Miku.
So you can race against all of your friends across all of the platform.
Wait, they never had multiplayer before?
Why are they saying that as if it's like the most mind-blowing thing ever?
Dude, what?
They didn't have crash platform multiplayer before?
Oh my
god.
Gaming is...
No way.
That's all I want.
Okay.
That got Miku.
Game of the... Pierce it up.
And I have everything.
Across a dark fantasy world.
Okay.
Not gonna lie.
And I'm kind of a vast story that it causes time.
Nintendo's Super Mario Kart.
I'm sorry, buddy.
But do you have Steve and Miku in your racing game?
Bro, that guy was doing tricks on his mine cart.
Bloodborne?
That's... That was actually crazy.
I was not... I... I thought that... The twist just kept coming and coming and coming.
The fuck?
What's this?
Is this... Devil May... Devil May Cry?
This?
No way.
There's no way that's Devil May Cry.
I was gonna say...
He is not edgy enough.
I know.
So it was like Devil May Cry.
I was like, no fucking way.
He does not look edgy enough for Devil May Cry.
Oh, this is before...
Oh, I rewind.
This is before she turned into whatever the fuck the candle lady was.
Oh, I need to undo the sins of ruin.
In this time...
Or maybe the next...
You'll find...
How to save us all.
Oh!
Alright.
Is this JRPG?
Or is this action JRPG?
Or is this Souls?
Souls.
Is it Souls?
I feel like everything's Souls now.
I feel like that's, like, the next genre.
For shooters, it's Extraction Shooter, and now, now for, like, any other game, it's Souls-like.
Oh, it's Code Vein 2!
Never heard of Code Vein 1 before.
I never heard of that game before.
Epic Games?
Fortnite?
I have?
I've played Code Vein before?
I...
When have I...
I don't remember playing Code Vein before.
I have?
I don't remember playing Code Vein.
Oh, my God.
I actually don't remember.
I have?
Oh, it was a sponsor!
Oh, I don't remember!
I don't remember!
I don't...
That was a very moody, cool new game.
That was End of Abyss, the debut title from Malmo, Sweden-based Section 9 Interactive, an atmospheric action-adventure game coming in 2026 to the Epic Games store and consoles.
Next, we'll step into the black-and-white world of rubber-hose animation...
People buy Epic Games...
People buy games on Epic Games that's not Fortnite?
Wait, what did it say?
...releasing later this year.
Here's a quick new look at the game and the reveal of a familiar voice.
Oh, it's the mouse one!
I want to play this one!
This game looks so cool!
Oh my god!
This game looks so fucking cool!
I love the art style.
Rats!
Yeah, I like the...
I like the style of this.
Troy Baker, of course.
Of course.
Troy...
It's gonna be like 40 years later and then Troy Baker will still be voicing a 20-year-old protagonist.
Alright, that's not all from Playside.
Now comes the announcement of another ambitious project from an independent Australian developer.
He'll be like 70 years old and he'll still be like voice acting the main character of whatever 20-year-old it is.
Like...
But this takes things to a whole new level.
It's a premium real-time strategy game built for PC based on one of the most iconic fantasy franchises in the world.
Any guesses?
What?
Let's take a look.
At this day and age, a real-time strategy...
Lord of the Rings?
Wait, is this...
Game of Thrones?
Is that...
Oh, it's Game of Thrones RTS.
You may think you know how the game is played.
An actual real-time strategy game in 2025.
Like...
I admire their bravery for the market they're trying to get into.
No, it's Game of Thrones and RTS.
Isn't the final season basically killed off Game of Thrones?
I heard the dragon one was a good show though.
You decide...
Like, I read that some...
One of the actors read the script and it was so fucking bad.
They were like walking around in London in midnight to contemplate their lives.
Their life or something.
Cause it was that bad.
They were like walking around and like in midnight.
Just trying to be like, I can't believe this is the script we got.
Wait, what?
So you kill one of them?
They go on...
They're now on your side?
What?
Is this Battle Mill Earth's successor?
Where...
Where was the gameplay trailer?
Like...
Yeah, the CGI looked so cool.
But we all know what RTS actually looks like.
Like...
Yeah, the CGI was so fucking cool.
But we all know what...
The...
The top down...
Outlook?
The great Tsiolkovsky on set.
One could count a million...
I don't understand.
RTS is...
We all know what RTS looks like.
It is said, if they were out there, they would have visited Earth.
What's this?
What game is this?
It's an FPS game.
Oh.
My answer is...
Maybe...
They will visit us.
But time has not come yet...
For this.
You know what that game reminds me of?
That robot game.
With the hot robot twins.
Oh, it is!
It is!
It...
Yeah, I was gonna say...
Is this Atomic Heart?
This has to be Atomic Heart.
With the hot robot twins.
And I was like...
There she is!
Oh my god!
Is that a dinosaur?
The robot dinosaur!
On a good time...
Don't stop me!
Oh nice!
Have a good time, Captain.
There's new robot twins?!
Oh my god, they're gold.
You know they're- OH MY!
Don't stop it, don't stop it.
Okay- OH!
Wow, okay.
They know- they know what the people want, that's for sure.
They- they- they know what they're doing.
Oh yeah, speaking of Borderlands 2, that's crazy what they did.
Before the release of the new Borderlands 2.
What did they do?
Okay, so you know how Borderlands 2 was free?
Apparently people found out that there's spyware installed in Borderlands 2.
That's why they made it free.
But these are all, like, allegations, so people don't know if it's true or not.
Like, the devs haven't made any- they didn't make any, um, official statement about it.
But people were saying that they- they added something new that wasn't in the old Borderlands 2.
When it showed up, I was in the lab.
I didn't even see it.
You know?
I felt that same fear, though.
But it's like- it's all allegations, though.
I held a sense of my own powerlessness.
How did the whole of humanity miss it?
And did we actually- What's this?
Oh, that's like more information.
But yeah, if you look at Borderlands 2 right now on Steam, it's getting heavily review-bombed.
Because of it.
That- this is Atomic Heart 2.
I like how they're like- how do we improve on the- the hot robot twins?
We make them gold.
Like, that's how you improve it.
Real and true.
The Cube.
Oh wait, it's another one?
MMO.
They were right.
Cold is kinda hot though.
It's like... Oh, I actually don't know what this game is about, but everyone was talking about it.
Oh, it's a beat-em-up.
Oh.
It's the arcade beat-em-ups.
I mean, it reminded me of it.
The art style.
The art style looks like an arcade beat-em-up.
Like the classic ones.
I was gonna say, it's like, you know, you're buying an iPhone and you're like, do you want the silver, the platinum, or the gold iPhone?
This is only fun with friends.
I'm sorry.
That's it.
This beat-em-up is only fun when you have friends to play this with.
Real.
True.
Friends.
Slop.
Oh, it's not slop.
It's literally the only reason it's fun.
That's what it's for.
That's why it's an arcade game.
Arcade games are fun when you're playing it with your friends.
This isn't hell.
Oh, it went straight to...
Capcon.
Oh, is this...
Uh...
Ghost...
Is this...
Oh, is this Onimusha?
Yeah, this is Onimusha, the zombie.
I recognize the... the... zombies.
Wait, why is he British?
Or Australian?
Wait, can you talk again?
Did he just sound...
Because it's cool.
Do the suck!
Do the thing!
Was it?
Like...
Was that actually a Japanese accent?
With the... the main character.
Oh my god.
Low key core.
Oh, that looks so good.
Yes!
The suck!
Give us what we want!
Oh!
Hello.
I'm only here for the suck.
That was a new look at Onimusha, Way of the Sword...
I hope I get sponsored to play this new game.
It is coming in 2026 and will be playable this summer...
Please!
I played Onimusha 1 and 2 on stream.
I'm a real fan.
I'm not here...
I'm not one of those fake fans that only played Onimusha...
Onimusha 4 just because it got released.
...to create an insane digital puppeteering pipeline.
It's actually a thing.
What you're about to see is running completely in real time and unreal.
And I cannot wait to play it.
Here is an unexpected new game announcement...
What is it?
...that combines comedic storytelling and arcade fighting action.
Check this out.
I'm a real fan.
Oh, this is all in-game.
What the fuck is this?
An unadoptable orphan.
Is this like that...
What was it called?
The boxing game but with Muppets?
What was that boxing game?
From Nintendo.
But with Muppets.
Punch out.
It's Muppet Punch out.
It's- It's-
Chief or- Move, die!
Muppet out.
Oh, yeah, yeah boy.
Oh, yeah boy.
Eat red, grab burnt toe, car below- Wait, it is!
Wait, it is!
Muppet Punch out!
Oh my god!
Muppet felt that box.
Oh my god, it is!
What the fuck?
That's actual gameplay.
Holy shit.
Okay, that actually looks... I actually want to play that game.
That actually looks fun.
Day one by now.
Finally.
People were saying, like, oh man, Summer Game Fest has been so poor with game releases.
This, that game saved the entire show.
Summer Game Fest was saved by one trailer, and it was Muppet Punch-Out.
And Sonic Racing.
I can't wait for Muppet Mike Tyson.
Oh, is this Friend Slop?
Killer Inn.
It's Troubles and Terrors Town.
But, like...
Killer Inn is a murder mystery action game.
The killers lurk elusively in plain sight.
Kill someone, and a clue will remain.
Hair, fingerprints, blood, clothes.
The lambs scramble to find clues.
One step closer to unmasking the culprits.
Who is guilty will eventually come to light.
Wolves win by killing every lamb.
Lambs win by rooting out every wolf.
Such simple rules.
But there's so much more to this game of murder.
Yeah, it's Troubles and Terrors Town.
A quick quest to level up.
Buy items with the gold you earn.
Loot chests for weapons and armor.
Steel items blow up...
Oh, yeah, no.
This is 100% Friend Slop.
This...
This is a streamer game.
No, this is... this is a streamer game.
Victory are clear.
You would do well to remember.
Deceit and deduction are your strongest weapons in this game of life or death.
Your invitation...
By Square Enix...
Okay, I was gonna say the cosmetics.
Yeah, that makes sense.
I was gonna say Square Enix is pride of this?
That was for a 24-player multiplayer game from Square Enix where you compete in a game of life or death.
Yeah, I was like Square Enix developed this.
All right, it's hard to believe this next game was first announced at TGA in 2021.
And though it's been a while, their recent tech tests prove that some things are definitely worth the wait.
I'm, of course, talking about Ark Raiders.
This is one of the most anticipated games of the year.
And we're excited to share a new trailer, which will tell you more...
That's an extraction shooter, too, right?
...the world of Spranza and the long-awaited launch date coming later this year.
From Embark Studios, here's the world premiere of the release date trailer for Ark Raiders.
This is also an extraction shooter?
Yeah, but Doki, this is a good extraction shooter.
Okay, okay, everyone says that.
Everyone always says that.
Bro, so is like Marathon Killer.
You don't have to kill Marathon.
They already pulled the funding for it.
Yeah.
It can't be killed if it's sort of already on life support.
Surround yourself with resourceful friends.
Here, you.
I mean, it's been development for so long.
The only issue is that every FPS game, like, it has been, like, extraction shooter.
After extraction shooter.
I'm just tired of extraction shooters.
Everyone's trying to kill off Tarkov, but, like, Tarkov literally has, like, the hold on the player base.
Trust us, this will finally be the one.
That's right, that's why the War Operators is coming October 30th, 2025, for PC and console.
Only Tarkov will kill Tarkov.
They tried, though!
Tarkov did try to kill itself, but they, like, survived.
Don't you guys remember?
The whole thing about, like, the expansion pack or whatever was, like, X amount of money, and it lived.
And they, and they still, and they still lived through it.
Somehow, they, they still lived.
I'm, I'm personally tired of extraction shooters.
Like, even Tarkov can't be the one to, to, to, to kill their own game.
Is this Dune?
Is it good?
I heard it came out now.
I heard it's out now, isn't it?
It's an MMO, right?
No, it's an MMO.
Yeah, it's, like, a survival game.
The thing is, I didn't grow up watching Dune, so, like, I don't have any, like, nostalgia towards it.
Or, like, wanting to be in that world type deal.
No, I never watched any of the Dune movies, or read any of the books of Dune.
So, like, I have no, none of the nostalgia feeling, or, like, the feeling of wanting to be in the Dune universe.
So, me looking at this, I'm just like, alright.
I'm just like, alright.
Because I have no context whatsoever.
It's, like, it's, like, Arcane.
So, like, you know how, like, I refuse to watch Arcane?
Because, like, I don't, I'm scared of it making me like League of Legends, and wanting to play League of Legends, and I do not want that on, on me.
Like, I do not wish for that to happen to me.
Um, and, so, I've never watched Arcane.
And then, my friends would be like, you don't understand.
This person shows up, and then this thing happens.
And I was like, I have zero context of anything you say.
Like, like, I, I don't understand.
Like, I, I, I've never heard, I don't know any lore, anything lore related to League.
So, like, none of that makes sense to me.
I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I,
I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I, I The thing is, I'm scared.
But what if I actually get into League?
The only thing I know about League is KDA.
That's the only thing.
And Imagine Dragons, because for some reason they always hire them for all their songs.
And it all sounds... Okay, Hot Take.
Alright, I don't know what the fuck trailer I was just watching, but Hot Take, Imagine Dragons songs all sound the same to me.
I feel like it's just, it's all, it's so similar.
Is this Genshin?
Or...
Is this...
Oh, it's Wittering Waze?
Oh.
It's Wuwa.
Is that what you guys call it?
The Wuwas?
Oh my god, Wuwa.
What happened while I was...
So, I hear the...
The victors show no mercy to the defeated.
People here despise weakness, worship strength, and crave glory.
I never doubted that he would end up here.
I'm gonna be curious.
What ending have you penned for Septimont this time?
Ooh!
Sponsor me!
A rat?
Such a tiny nuisance.
I know all your secrets.
I mean, it looks pretty.
I feel like all the, like, really beautiful, pretty games are all, like, platformers.
I don't know.
They're all, like, platform-related type games.
Like, a lot of games that are, like, have, like, unique art styles, or, like, really interesting stories, are mostly platformers.
As part of NextFest.
What you're about to see next is a stop-motion co-op platformer.
Ooh!
See?
Look at that!
Platformer!
Co-op stop-motion!
Look at that!
It's a platformer.
Oh, that's cute.
I like that.
It reminds me of the yarn game.
What's it called?
Oh, yeah, and it ticks, too.
It reminds me of the yarn game.
Unraveled.
Yeah, this reminds me of Un- This looks like Unraveled.
The art style's cute, though.
Don't you see?
We can't.
Come on, fight
it!
Yeah, it's Unraveled Core.
It's cute, though.
Out of words.
It's really cute.
I like the art style.
2026.
What a really unique and different game.
This August signals the release of Mafia The Old Country, the next entry in the acclaimed Mafia franchise from the team at Hangar 13.
I remember seeing that trailer when they previewed it.
I love Mafia.
Here is the Summer Game Fest trailer.
The trail burns because it can only come from someone close.
Mafia is such a good game.
I love the story.
I love you like a friend.
It's a me, Manuel.
I work here.
Sorry.
My family.
My beautiful daughter, Isabelle.
Yeah, TK.
TK makes the Mafia series.
They've always done the Mafia series.
You're breaking my heart.
You're gonna ruin the family.
If this is how it'll be.
The Dawn's noticed you, Enzo.
This is an opportunity.
Do you wish to commit to this family?
Oh.
Enzo!
We can't let them get away!
When Isabella became involved, it became our business.
I saw a shop.
That was like a witch shop today.
I almost bought a modern spell book.
But then I was like, no, that's a scam.
Because I was like, oh my, it would be cool if I bought this book.
And then just like read it to you guys.
And like start trying to cast some spells.
It was like modern witch spells.
And I was like, ooh.
And I was like, no.
Even as a joke.
That's too much money.
I was like, it's a funny joke stream.
But I was like, no.
This is a scam.
Like I was reading the spells.
I was like, aww.
Yeah, but Dopefield was funny.
It was worth it.
But yeah, it was like a sh- Like, you know like those like modern witchcraft shop- Witchcraft shops.
And it was like, I saw one.
And I was like, whoa.
That's- Oh my god.
Oh, that's cute.
Yeah, where they have- Oh, Duplo?
No, it's Lego!
It's not Duplo.
It's not for children.
Yeah, it's like a- It takes two, but what if you're Lego?
This is literally- It takes two, but Lego.
What the fuck is modern witchcraft?
It's- It's like- Lots of candles.
There were lots of candles.
Lots of like tarot cards.
They had like a whole collection of different- Okay, what's funny is like the capitalism of tarot cards.
Because there was like Game of Thrones tarot cards.
And like, like random fucking tarot cards from different brands and stuff.
And then lots and lots of crystals.
And those like, um, those like paper wrap things.
I don't know what it's called.
There's like- Oh, Summer Game Fest!
Like thick paper wrap things for like, uh- I'm Carol Morse, voice actor for a few familiar faces you might have grown up with on Nickelodeon.
I don't know what it's called.
Some with school suits, thank you.
Some with science smarts and some with serious attitude.
Nickelodeon has always been about wild worlds and weirder characters.
And while I'm mostly sworn to secrecy today- Spongebob?
I'm thrilled to have a hand in revealing something that brings a lot of those characters together like never before.
I hope you enjoy the first look at Nicktoons and the Dias of Disney.
Yeah, cause that's- that's Sadie.
Yee!
What?
Nicktoons!
Wait!
A new Nicktoons game?
A brave and wise- Oh my god!
Wait!
Is that Timmy?
No way!
Oh my god!
I love Nicktoons!
Spongebob?
Danny Phantom?
Timmy?
Awww!
Never have hope.
It's been almost two years since players first stepped into the role of the puppet to save the speed of glass, disease, and puppet friends in Lies of He.
Overture is a DLC expansion of Lies of He.
The transport player is back in time with new characters, environments, and of course- If you hope, you'll only set yourself up for disappointment.
Oh!
The hope, the happiness just drained from her eyes!
I legitimately thought it was gonna be the Nicktoon games with Danny Phantom, Timmy, Spongebob, and- I forgot the fourth- Jimmy Neutron.
Was it Jimmy?
I forgot!
Who was the fourth person?
I forgot the fourth guy.
I- I- I- yeah, it was it Jimmy?
It was- yeah, Jimmy, Danny, and- Timmy, and Spongebob.
I-
I dared to dream, only to- to be disappointed yet again.
I don't wanna play Nicktoons on the stream.
Oh my god.
That actually, like, was my childhood.
Like, I- I- I legitimately was- got so fucking happy thinking we were gonna get a new Nicktoon team.
Like, they even got Sandy in- oh my god.
I- I had so much hope.
I was like, Nickelodeon creating a game, trying to do something outside of Spongebob?
That's fucking crazy.
Oh, look.
Oh, new- oh, today!
Lies of PDLC is today.
Yes, that's right.
Overture is available today across all platforms- Download now, guys!
Download now, it's today!
Next up, the small video game, publisher Serenity Forge, based in Boulder, Colorado- Shared this game with a few months back with a DM that said- Doki Doki Literature Club meets Silent Hill.
That's me- oh!
I was like, me?!
I was like, oh my god, Doki Bird!
Oh, that's interesting.
Doki Doki Literature Club with Silent Hill.
And farming?!
Oh, this is a horror farming game, isn't it?
Isn't this a horror farming game?
Was- didn't they have like, a preview of this game?
Yeah, I remember there was a- the- there was like, a demo of it.
The- there was like, a demo of it.
Okay, how is this Doki Doki Literature Club?
If they did like, Stardew Valley and Silent Hill?
Like, that makes more sense.
Like- I- where- where does the Doki Doki Literature Club come from?
I- Fact- fractured blooms.
There's a hunger that feeds and blooms.
And I will feed.
And I will bloom.
I will bloom.
Yeah, it's just looks- it's just a farming- Ooh, the artwork's pretty.
It's just- it's a farming horror game.
Isn't there like 3 different farming horror games that are coming out?
Like...
Where the fuck is the Doki Doki Literature Club coming from?
Blade and Soul of Nioh.
Now on Steam.
I have...
Oh, what's this?
Is this Genshin?
Oh no, it was still from that game.
No, it's new.
Oh look, you can be a dog!
Not all anime games are Genshin.
It's like, when you're like, is this Bloodborne?
And I'm like, is this Genshin?
We are not the same.
Genshin?
Wait, no, that guy is from that one show.
Yeah, isn't that One Punch Man?
Wait, what is he doing here?
Wait, what is he?
Wait, what's Sartama doing here?
What is he doing?
What?
I'm so confused.
What is he doing here?
Jump Force?
Oh my god, okay.
If they ever announce Jump Force 2, I would be so fucking happy.
Guys, Jump Force is another game that I wanna play.
I wanna play on stream.
There's so many games.
Someone help me write down all the games that I say I wanna play on stream, because I'm gonna forget.
I...
No, of course.
Guys, no.
You guys need to know.
My channel is all about ironic...
Ironic...
Shit.
I play a lot of games that are known to be not the greatest.
I literally played...
What's his name?
World...
The Balon Wonderland?
I literally played Balon Wonderland on stream.
Just cause I...
I needed to know how bad it was.
Bro, I just found out recently.
Someone finally modded the game.
Where like...
There's...
They added one more control into Balon Wonderland.
Where the...
Where it's not just...
Where you can actually jump in the game.
They...
Someone...
This year...
Modded the game so you can finally...
Jump.
Without having to wear a costume.
That's crazy.
Revolutionary mod.
And then the guy was like, I am not making more mods for this game.
I just wanted to...
Finally be able to jump.
Okay, 7...
I've never watched 7 Deadly Sins.
So...
I'm just like...
Okay.
5.6 is available today.
This is a technological showcase set in the world of The Witcher 4.
Human creator is now fully integrated into Unreal Engine.
Oh, it's an advertisement for Unreal Engine.
I can do that.
VTubers had that technology.
Ha ha ha.
Oh, thank you so much for the raid, guys.
Also, thank you so much for the videos and sub.
Sorry if I can't think the subs in time, guys.
Cause like...
I have one monitor.
And like...
Right now...
It's like...
All I see is like...
Chat.
And...
My OBS.
I'm literally watching this through my OBS window.
Oh!
Is this a Jurassic World...
Uh...
To nurture...
The zoo one.
To find hope...
Yeah, Jurassic World Evolution.
Awww.
That's cute.
Oh,
nice!
I like Jurassic World Evolution.
That was fun.
We worked so hard to get the fucking raptors last time.
So I can recreate the Chris Pratt scene.
It was worth it, though.
It was worth it, just to recreate the Chris Pratt scene.
We spent, like, hours trying to fucking get the raptors.
Ten years ago, we broke new ground with our first game, Shovel Knight.
Oh!
They're actually making a new game?
Today, I'm thrilled to share a world premiere look at our next IP, Mina the Hollower.
Mina continues our traditions of refining retro gameplay for a new generation.
It's a bone-chilling adventure that...
What if this game comes up before Silk Song?
All right, let's find out.
As Mina, a whip-wielding Hollower, you'll burrow through danger...
It will.
Toki, please stop.
A decade ago, we unearthed a groundbreaking legend.
This year, we're bringing our next bonafide classic.
Wow!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, she's a bride!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ten out of ten, she's a bride!
Oh, this is actual retro retro, oh.
That is heavy retro.
Yeah, it's like color.
It's like Game Boy.
It's like Game Boy game.
Yeah, no, it feels like a Game Boy game.
Oh, yeah!
Mickey Mousecapades, yeah!
Game Boy Advance?
Maybe.
It feels like a game, like a game, like, I don't know which generation, but it feels like a Game Boy.
All right.
This is a special one.
Our next game comes from a well-known developer that has done... Yeah.
What?
Kyle Bossman, everyone!
Okay, was this scripted or real?
Let's see what this says.
Is it scripted or... or is it actual?
Hey, Jeffy.
Everything is scripted.
If you're reading this, it means three things.
Number one, you're killing it at the fest with your oodles of natural charisma.
Oh, yeah.
Hundred scripting.
Available.
B, I'm at your house playing long darts with the fam.
And three, you're gonna do me a solid and skip that silksong trailer.
So you can pick my revolutionary VR gaming venture that will shock the industry probably.
A wet one on the lips, comma, waved.
All right.
Oh, Deadpool.
It's Deadpool.
I can't believe it.
Deadpool killed silksong.
I...
And it's VR.
Of course it is.
VR killed silksong.
I can't believe it.
Do people even play VR games anymore other than fucking VR chat?
I feel like VR was...
VR games was such a...
Was like an actual phase for gaming.
Like, I don't know anyone that actually plays VR games outside of VR chat.
I guess like Beat Rhythm games too.
Yeah, and then Beat Rhythm.
Beat Saber, yeah.
Yeah, Beat Saber.
I know VR still play VR for like...
VR chat and Beat Saber.
But I actually don't really know people that...
I feel like...
Or like Bruella Tag.
Bruella Tag personally has like...
Is incredibly popular with children.
I don't know why.
Brue...
With Neil Patrick Harris's Deadpool.
All right.
Neil Patrick Harris?
That was Neil!
The culmination of a decade of Techland's experience building survival horror games.
Legendary.
How Crane is back as the player character in this title that blends open world and action survival horror.
No way!
Barney Stinson?
That's Deadpool?
Wait for it.
I did not...
I did not realize that was Neil Patrick Harris.
The guy from the Smurfs movies?
I didn't realize he wasn't...
Oh yeah!
He was in Smurfs!
He's a narcissistic sociopath.
He's experimenting on humans like the lab rats.
What is this?
God only knows what the Baron's planning to do with those monsters.
Dying light?
Okay.
Wait until...
If he parkours, then we'll know.
Genshin?
Is this Genshin?
He's not parkouring.
How can he be dying light without...
Without parkour?
Okay, nevermind.
It's dying light.
Nevermind.
There we go.
But...
Now it's dying light.
I was like, you can't be dying light without parkour.
Parkour!
It's like...
This is...
Zombie games will always have like one thing that will make them different from other zombie games.
Dying light is parkour.
Uh...
Or other ones.
Oh, August 22nd.
Oh, wait.
That's not...
What is this?
Dying light...
Oh, is this a...
DLC?
Oh?
Watch more.
Oh, okay.
There's more.
Yeah, that has to be a DLC.
Yeah.
Dying light the beast.
Dying light the beast is coming on August 22nd.
Gamescom.
Ooh.
All right.
This next game draws inspiration from classic coming-of-age films to capture the highs and lows of adolescence.
The bonds of friendship...
The highs and lows of football.
Mixed cake comes from Beethoven Dinosaur and Annapurna Interactive.
And this is your exclusive new look at this game that plays like a love letter to teenage memories.
What are we doing?
Oh?
Oh.
Hanging out.
Getting buzzed.
I've gotta get out.
Did you know the 80s was 40 years ago?
You hit the ball.
Haha.
Stop.
To current enemies are up to kill.
It's time to look back on your greatest hits.
Doki, please.
This is clearly 80s Core.
This year, experience a retrospective like no other.
Beethoven and Dinosaur invites you to relive the teenage riot.
To spend one last night together, before school's out forever.
Oh my god, they're TPing!
You know what's crazy?
The teenagers and the young adults that were playing this game, will have no nostalgia over this.
They'll be like... To them, this would be like a weird... They'll be like, ooh, what's this?
Experience it for yourself.
Mixtape.
Nothing but the ones.
Yeah, because they'll be like, what the... I know like the young ones, like Gen Z or whatever, are like, what's a mixtape?
The Genshin?
Eventually they'll have a Genshin-n jersey, right?
Yeah, I find your destiny i see it.
There is no escaping it.
Eventually they'll be right.
This is Touhou?
I got Catie... She's so embarrassed and so sorry.
She sort of looked like Toho for a second.
Ah, it's cute.
Toki, please.
Toki, why are you like this?
She sort of looked like that Toho girl for like one second.
Okay, her staff looked like the Toho girl.
Oh, is this Hades?
Are your eyes okay?
Guys, is it sort of obvious that the only thing I know about Toho is...
is the little balls that come out and then also bad apple?
Is it obvious?
Because everyone would be like, oh look, they're Toho-ing.
Toho!
It's almost... oh my god, I was almost correct.
Look, her name is Toa.
It's just like Toho.
Oh my god!
Toho, Toho!
I'm almost... it's practically the same thing.
...with a whimsical spin on eastern mysticism.
Next, we want to introduce you to a game made by a first-time solo developer in Bangung, Indonesia.
With the help of nine of his friends, he's built an intense action beat-em-up with brutal hand-to-hand combat set in the hometown.
Wait!
Fuck!
This is Axe of Blood.
Oh, I thought that was the potato.
Or...
Sorry!
I was like, oh my god!
Is that... what was it called?
The hunt isn't over.
Killer Bean!
Sorry!
I thought that was a bean!
I was like, oh my god!
Is this Killer Bean?
A solo developer beat-em-up?
Haha!
Legit!
I thought...
I thought he was gonna be talking about Killer Bean!
I was so hyped!
I was so excited!
I mean, this looks fucking cool, though.
He said, solo developer beat-em-up?
Of course the first thing I thought of was Killer Bean.
Haha!
You're getting so...
Okay!
Killer Bean is...
Game of the Year.
You can't change my mind.
After...
Okay, if...
If the Sonic racing game doesn't come out...
At the same time as Killer Bean, then Killer Bean is Game of the Year.
I'm aiming for a solo dev with nine...
Okay, solo dev with nine of his friends?
That...
Is he a solo dev, or is he...
A dev with nine friends?
Sifu with guns.
Jeez.
Axe of Blood.
That's really...
Good, though.
The game looks nice.
Amazing what these solo devs can do today.
Now it is time for the reveal of the next...
What about his nine friends, Jeff?
The makers of TMNT Shredder's Revenge and Marvel Cosmic Invasion, which you saw a little bit earlier.
If you're like me, you've been waiting for more than a decade.
Sifu, if he wasn't a fucking coward.
If he had seafood...
Can't use a gun.
Oh, Toronto.
Yay!
Goodbye, Toronto.
The Vegans.
Okay.
I...
I don't think I'm afraid of a group called The Vegans.
I'm sorry.
If the other two were literally the robots and the demons...
Wait!
Is that...
Oh my god!
Is this Scott Pilgrim?
It's Scott Pilgrim!
Hmm...
I haven't seen my Manic Pixie Girl.
Oh, that...
But yeah, I swear to you, like...
The Vegans?
The Robots?
Or the Demons?
Like, I'm sorry, but like...
Why would you be afraid of the Vegans if there's Robots and Demons?
And now the Vegans makes sense.
They're very scary.
Have you seen them?
Yeah, this is a new peanut, I'm pretty sure.
I think...
The Scott Pilgrim movie was ahead of its time.
I think if the Scott Pilgrim movie was released later in the year...
later on...
Oh, it's an EX, so they...
It's like a...
Director's Cut.
Scott Pilgrim is back with his fist flying in a brand new brawling adventure in EX.
You'll battle through space-time and the streets of my hometown of Toronto...
It is a...
It is honestly...
Because it was a box office bust.
It wasn't...
It didn't do well financially.
But I feel like if they released it...
Like just...
Three to four years later...
That movie would do really well.
Her performance...
In Resident Evil Village.
Woo!
Oh!
We've been preparing delightful ways to make you suffer.
Oh, wait!
So enter the village if you dare.
We slash the price to be lower than ever for you simple little man things.
Still thirsty?
Worry not, you ungrateful wretch.
But there's plenty more fun to go around.
Now cease this foolishness.
And make your decision wise.
I'm looking at the Twitch chat.
You and them are...
Oh no.
Uh...
You and them are the same.
I'm looking at the...
The official broadcast of the Twitch chat.
Oh, okay.
Is that...
What's it called?
Oh wait, no.
They said the game name.
The first...
Yeah, it's first to send it.
Wow!
Since the dawn of time...
I wonder what would be the last game announcement.
Humankind has been obsessed with the hard.
Alright, guys.
Predictions.
What do you think would be the final game trailer?
That's so sorry.
Hahaha.
Now...
A glorious morning has dawned...
On something that simply...
Hard.
This game already looks...
I don't know.
I...
Scum.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
This game already looks...
I don't know.
Eat hard.
Oh, there's mechas at least.
Version 1.0 full launch.
I mean, this looks interesting.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
Not in...
I would say interesting.
It looks like something fun to play with friends for a few months.
Or a couple of weeks.
Come with me.
It's like a...
Just like a...
Sandbox-type deal.
Oh!
Oh...
New IP?
Alright, predictions.
New IP or... or... Sequel?
Where's the gameplay?
Okay, you're asking way too much in the Summer Game Fest.
You're at MindEyesGame.
It's literally coming out this month, and this is the first time I've heard about this game.
Wait, what?
What the fuck?
Hitman?
I'm Hakan Abrak, CEO of IO Attractive.
We can't wait for you to discover MindSight when it launches on June the 10th from Build-A-Rocket Boy and IO Partners.
And yes, you may have noticed...
I feel like this is the first time I've heard of this game.
It was shown last year.
That is how much I don't remember.
That's how generic it was.
That was so generic that I don't even remember it from last year.
This week we finally revealed 007 First Light to the world.
Finally, real food.
Finally, we can be fed.
It's coming in 2026.
But we want to make the wait more exciting.
We are bringing someone into Hitman, the world of assassination, who is very dear to the Bond universe.
Let's take a look.
Huh?
Another announcement?
Who?
Oh my god, Tom Cruise.
Who knows?
Your target is the elusive shadow banker, known only as Le Chiffre, a financial mastermind was suspected...
Wait!
Mads... Mads... Mads...
Mads...
Mickelson?
Wait!
That's the first...
The first...
James Bond...
Not the first, sorry.
I meant...
From Casino Royale.
The first movie in Casino Royale.
Yeah.
Mr. Rengang.
He's too impatient, and Miss Bai, well...
She likes a drink.
Don't know about the newcomer, Mr. Smith, though.
He's the only wild card.
Well, this is turning into an interesting evening.
Welcome to the VIP room here at the Casino Monarchic.
Reaper.
Unusual name.
Names are for fragments.
Wouldn't you agree, Mr. Le Chiffre?
Le Chiffre?
I still can't believe Mads...
uh...
Mickelson...
Is...
Um...
Was in that...
The Lion King Mufasa movie, and he was the one that went...
Bye-bye!
I can't believe that was him!
He was the one that was like...
Bye-bye!
However...
Hitman is live right now.
He was the one that did...
Bye-bye!
And I asked a fellow Danish friend to join me here.
As a matter of fact, he is here with us...
Yes, that was him!
He was...
He was the...
He was the main lion!
He was the main evil lion!
Oh my god!
He has such a unique face.
I didn't even realize he was Danish.
He plays...
Oh my god, he's so old now.
Oh my...
I already knew him from Hannibal.
But you're also Agent 47's next target as Le Chiffre, the villain we know from Casino Royale.
How old is he now?
That's it.
He's so old now.
I've always had a deep love for this character.
It's a role that means a lot to me, because of a lot of reasons.
So, when Haggard gave me the chance to step into the chutes of Le Chiffre once again...
He's 60!
He's literally a grandpa!
He's a gilf!
He's more confident.
He's dangerous.
He's not just bringing mine, hiding behind a desk.
He's visceral, unpredictable, and ruthless.
I was like, that's my sugar daddy right there!
You'd be sugar grandpa!
So this mission is set in a casino in Paris.
We want to make an homage to the movie Casino Royale, while keeping surprises for our players.
James Bond and Agent 47 have a very different set of skills.
I think it's the beard.
The beard makes him look even older.
And the mission will be handled in very different creative ways.
Yeah, he's not gonna beat me in poker.
He's gonna figure something else out.
No, I guess it is not just about the shot.
It's about the bluffing around the table this time?
Yeah, sure, exactly.
Le Chiffre is always like two steps ahead of you.
He reads you before you read him, so it's a little like bringing a chess player to a poker game.
We built a mission to allow several parts, unexpected characters, appearances, and even custom poker mechanics.
Wow!
You can play poker in Hitman?
Nice!
That's the best part.
We wanted to surprise you, so the team is updating the game as we speak.
Oh!
Oh, it's launching today!
Wait, what does this say?
And if you play it, you will unlock a unique reward in 007 first life.
Wait, it's only for 30 days?
Wait, you can only download this for 30...
You can only play this for 30 days, though?
That sucky suck.
Yeah.
Great stuff.
Alright, now here's the announcement of a new party game coming later this year.
Bye-bye!
I think it's copyright.
I think.
With over 1 million LEGO bricks, 300 minifigures, and over 700 trillion minifigure companies.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm down and play it just for the event.
If it's just 30, like 30 days.
I think it had to be...
I think it's related to copyright.
Cause, like, sometimes, like, it's very expensive.
Especially if it's, like, based off a movie and stuff.
Um...
For, like, like, uh, to pay, like, copyright for the movie company.
To use the character.
Is World of Assassination just like that?
I don't know.
I feel like the licensing is also not that cheap, though.
I don't mind playing the...
Playing that on stream.
Just cause it's only 30 days, so it's, you know...
I hate limited...
Aw, man.
I hate limited time events.
If it's, like, something cool like that.
Oh, this is like...
Oh!
It's Mario Party!
It's LEGO Mario Party!
Oh, it's literally called LEGO Party.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Alright, is this $50?
Is it...
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Alright.
I need to know, though.
How much?
Are they gonna make you pay $40 to $80?
No, wait.
No, Doki.
It's $80.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
You're right.
I forgot.
New games are...
You're like...
Guys, remember when everybody complained about how expensive Switch 2 and the games are?
...and the open beta starts next week.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Remember that?
Fucking hypocrites.
You guys, I knew you guys would just fucking eat that shit up.
No matter.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Let's see what it means to getting into some serious...
We can't have this happen.
And then the moment of Switch 2 comes out, everyone's posting pictures.
Posting pictures of it.
Like, talking about Mario Kart and everything.
And I'm just like, fucking hypocrites.
I know.
I knew it.
I called it out.
I was like, they can do anything they want.
And you guys will eat that shit up no matter what happens.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Nintendo can do whatever the fuck they want.
And you'll be like yum yum.
Yummy yummy.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Now, their ship is flying.
I didn't buy...
I didn't pre-order the Switch 2 or bought the Switch 2.
because I never buy consoles on launch because usually there's something wrong with there will always be something wrong on launch so I just wait I don't I'm I I don't care much about FOMO I'm proud to reveal to you the next game from Toronto based drink box studios the team behind the The hype joke is missing out.
Who the fuck is doing a hype train on the Summer Games Award?
Dude... There's a hype train on the Summer Games Award.
What the fuck?
Jeff does not need that money.
They're literally paying Jeff to do this, these trailer announcements.
Oh, hey!
Guacca!
That game was fun.
They don't... Yeah, Guacca made it.
I saw that.
That's a funny game.
Yeah, that... Yeah, we did.
It's at level 11?!
That's what the fuck!
His hype train's at level 12, guys!
I...
He has a level 12 hype train right now.
Spreading this blight.
You hover it too, I see.
This seems Hades-like.
A little.
Oh!
Jesus!
I'm not that sold on the... Not gonna lie, for me, I'm not that sold on the art style.
Should you fall?
Pray the vultures consume you before the Black Deaths.
It's like... It feels... I know that... Oh my god, that's... That's freaky.
Uh... For me, I'm not too sold on the art style.
The 3D portion looks way too 3D when it's mixed with the 2D.
Lighted coming up right after the show in Day of the Devs.
Alright, next is a first-person survival action horror game from Team 5.
Like, when I saw the horse... The dead horse... Um... I wasn't like... I don't know.
The art style was like, not my favorite.
The 3D looked a little out of place, yeah.
That's how I felt.
Zombie game?
Oh hey, it's Mudfish again.
Wait, they're everywhere.
Ooh, Team Cloud.
Oh... Ooh...
Ahhhh!
Okay, these zombies look freaky.
I'm a little... These zombies give... These zombies... Oh god, okay.
These zombies give a very, very uncanny valley.
Like...
There's something weird of how they look like.
It's very uncanny.
Yeah, they look so... They're like a little... It's like a baby...
Like... They're like fucking smooth as hell for some reason.
Oh god.
Okay, but is this like...
Is this a tech demo or an actual gameplay?
We're not trying to get watchdogs here.
Like...
I don't know.
I wonder if this is... Is this actual gameplay or...
Or like... Is this a tech demo?
Cause this looks really good for a real gameplay.
Yeah, they look way too...
Oh!
I'm closing my eyes.
I can't.
Oh, I... I...
Oh my god, I kicked a baby!
I...
I do not like what they look like.
Yes, okay.
I didn't know.
They're just way too moisturized for zombies.
Cause you know how zombies are supposed to be like...
Rotten, dead, dry.
I...
I don't like how shiny they are.
I was like...
Someone...
It's like somebody put like...
Baby oil...
On all these zombies.
And I don't like it.
Well...
Yeah, they're like...
It's like...
Yeah...
Hey, make a break.
Oh...
Ouch...
That's so funny...
Nice and salty...
Yak...
Oh, it wouldn't None!
I
mean, it looks nice.
The CGI.
Okay, that looks fucking cool.
Oh my god, okay.
I'm sorry for those who are jamming right now and being really fucking hyped about Mecha Break.
But like, this is just all CGI so there's no gameplay.
So I'm just like vibing.
But like, I love all the memes about the new Marvel fighting game.
With like, Capcom getting cucked and Marvel going away with, what's that, the other studio?
I love all those memes.
They're so fucking funny.
Yeah, with like Marvel and Arc Systems works walking away and then Capcom in the corner being like, I don't understand.
I love those memes.
They're so funny.
Yeah, I know they showed gameplay Mecha Break, but like, I don't know.
I think it's just me being like, it's been me watching these trailers and stuff from game shows for so many years now that like, in-game, like CGI stuff, just like, if they're showing mostly CGI, I like mostly tune out.
Because I just want to know what the game actually looks like.
Because it can be really fucking beautiful, the CGI and everything.
But like, if the game fucking sucks, like, I...
I know, I know the gameplay's out there for Mecha Break, because it's been out for a bit.
But I'm just like, when I'm watching trailers, I like, tune out of like CGI trailers.
Because I'm mostly like this.
I want to see the gameplay.
I want to see how it is when I'm actually playing the game.
Not when I'm watching a movie.
Wait.
Yeah, this looks like Grounded with Guns.
We find a way.
Ooh, this looks interesting.
Yeah, it looks like Grounded with Guns.
Yeah.
Wait,
what?
Which one?
There's so many.
Happy birthday to you.
To you.
Oh, Resident Evil.
Oh.
Wait, is this the final game trailer?
Wait, is this how they're ending it?
Day.
Happy birthday.
Huh?
And to celebrate early, a special message from Takeuchi-san.
Guys.
Guys, I think this is the ending trailer, guys.
There's no way Resident Evil is not the ending trailer for the showcase.
Wait, that's it?
Oh, Baited again.
Thank you, Takuchi-san, for that very special message.
We cannot wait for when the time is right to share more, leading into the anniversary of the Resident Evil.
Now it's time for the next big update.
We got baited.
Aww.
God, why?
Every time I start feeling hope, I can't believe it.
Who's Kenny Omega?
Oh, it's a wrestler.
Oh!
What the fuck?
Okay.
What the fuck is going on?
Ingrid?
Oh, that's how they announced the new characters for Street Fighter 6?
Is that it?
Oh!
Oh shit!
A million dollars.
What's this?
Holy shit, this has been almost a two-hour summary game fest.
This looks like a good game for- if that's because of lobbies, it looks like a fun game for your members.
No, it looks like a battle royale.
Wouldn't it be funny if this is an extraction shooter?
What- Oh, it's a- is this a hero shooter?
Oh, it's a hero shooter.
It's not bad.
It's a hero shooter.
But, like, capture the flag.
Yeah, it's capture the flag, hero shooter.
But, like, Hades related?
That was Last Flag, a new online action game from the new indie studio Night Street Games, which is the ultimate game of capture the flag set in the 1970s, as you saw.
Oh no, I said 80s.
Not Hades.
Next, we have a beautiful new trailer for a souls-like action RPG game developed in China by Lenzi, Wu Chang, Fallen Feathers, which is launching on July 24th.
Oh, that's not- that's quite soon.
I never heard of this one before.
Oh.
I feel like there's- Oh.
Yeah, I remember this being teased previously.
Oh, yeah, I remember!
I remember this.
I remember seeing this.
I thought it looked really interesting.
Cause it's based off of, like, uh...
Um...
Was it based off of Chinese mythologies, right?
Yeah.
I remember being really interested in this.
It was based off of Chinese.
Cause I remember I saw, like, the wheeled kid.
The- the fire wheeled kid.
Yeah.
Neza.
Isn't he in there?
Right?
He was in there, right?
Okay.
What will it take...
To finally...
Awaken you?
Yeah, I remember.
Cause I was like, oh!
Oh, all the outfits are cute!
The outfits are cute.
I'm- I'm excited for that game.
That game looks really fun.
And I like Chinese mythologies.
Guys.
All.
Gotta rescue Mom.
This is what we gotta protect.
We cannot choose where we call people's dreams get smashed.
What's this?
Where is the Wu-Tang Clan?
What's that?
What?
Is it the Wu-Tang Clan?
Make...
No way?
What?
Wu-Tang Rise?
It's...
Wait, the Wu-Tang Clan made a video game?
Rise of the Receiver.
Presented by GhostfaceKiller.
From rappers to game developers.
Damn.
I was like so...
It looks cool, the art style.
A new title from the 53-member Brass Lion Entertainment.
Now, here's a new look at Guild Wars 2, which has new updates, including player housing, and is free to play.
This weekend, to celebrate SGF, you can take advantage of double XP, all weekend long.
MMO.
My calling takes me far from home, where shared struggles form fast bonds.
My greatest advantage?
Adaptability.
Their greatest weakness.
Me.
My story.
My story is yours.
Toki, don't disrespect your elders.
I just don't play MMOs, guys.
I...
I'm just not an MMO player.
I hear MMO, but I'm like...
Oh, is this MapleStory?
Oh wait, is this Genshin?
Oh, it's Star...
I went through so many different games.
Sorry, I just realized the game title is literally right there.
Star Dive.
Yeah.
One of them will eventually be Genshin, right?
Okay.
You can't lie.
This reminded me of...
This sort of looks like Genshin.
Okay, there's Wuwa.
Look though!
Oh my god, look!
There's Genshin!
I knew it!
Eventually, Genshin will show up.
I fucking knew it.
Guys, I was right.
Genshin will show up.
I did it.
Oh shit, Marvel Rivals.
Let's go.
Wait, Marvel Rivals is on the Epic Store?
Really?
I guess cause like...
It's also a separate launcher in the end.
No, this is for Epic.
Oh?
Oh yeah, Cyberpunk is on Nintendo Switch too.
Yeah.
Everyone...
That one guy was thinking it was Silksong.
I bet you that one guy freaked out cause he thought it was about Silksong.
Enter a surreal world where you're a down-as-locked outcast who has to battle his inner demons, literally, in this action roguelike.
He is into the unwell.
You heard that guy cheer?
He was like, Oh!
Oh, what the fuck is this?
Has Summer...
Was Summer Game Fest always this fucking long?
I feel like there's been like more...
I feel like there's been a lot of trailers this year.
Yeah, this...
This one is...
A lot longer.
The 3D with the...
Uh...
With the old timey animation does not work well for me.
I don't know.
If you're gonna do old timey animation style...
I don't...
3D just doesn't work with it.
I don't like the 3D.
And it looks...
Yeah, it does look unique, but...
For me, there's something off.
You still look a little...
Into the unwell.
There's just something off about it.
Mixing the two art styles together.
But that's just my opinion.
Oh, Splitgate 2!
When we started Splitgate in our dorm room, we just wanted to make a game we could play with our friends.
And 20 million of you played with us.
Now, with the help from our amazing community...
Wait, they made Splitgate 1?
With like...
In the dorm room?
It was like that...
Because I grew up playing Halo.
And I'm tired of playing the same Call of Duty every year.
And I wish we could have Titanfall 3.
Whoa!
Is he allowed to say that?
Jeff?
Is this scripted?
Is he allowed to say that?
What if you could portal to entirely different worlds?
Whoa!
Jeff, are you sure he could say that?
He got his microphone down!
And it's fucking awesome!
Whoa!
Oh my god!
Jeff!
The Advertisers!
The Ad...
Jeff must have been like...
Oh no!
Holy shit!
I don't know if that was scripted or not, guys!
He gets the kill!
Now that's how you portal!
He he he he he!
Oh, nice!
Okay, that's cool.
I never got a chance to play Splitgate because we never got pervs for it when it came up.
I wanna play it.
And then by the time...
By the time I could finally try it up, people were just too good.
There's no way.
I don't know.
I feel like Jeff would not.
Like...
You know, like, I'm tired of how shitty Call of Duty is.
And where the fuck is Titanfall 3 respawn?
In like, a global...
Like, in a...
You know...
It's just...
I don't know if Jeff would actually be allowed that.
Where is the line though?
Yeah.
Yeah, but you're not supposed to say that!
In front of, like, a developer!
In front of all these big developers!
Like...
Jeff is like, thinking...
What do we do with this game?
From the talented minds of RGG Studio in Japan.
Ooh!
He's been removed.
What's this?
Is this Yakuza?
Detective Yakuza?
Yakuza, but like, the police?
1943.
Wait...
1943 Yakuza?
Wait, it is Detective Yakuza.
Oh!
It's like LA Noire!
But like...
Japan Noire!
Oh shit!
Yeah, it looks really good!
Yeah, that's cool!
That's really, really good.
And then like, uh...
What's his name?
The eyepatch guy shows up here.
Wait, it is...
Wait, he looks like LA Noire.
Majima.
Yeah, Majima shows up.
Project Sentry.
Oh my god.
Stranger Than Heaven.
Oh, it's new IP!
That looks really interesting.
Yeah, Majima just comes up, and she's like, JK, it's Yakuza.
You saw it at TJ last year.
Project Sentry set in 1915, and now the full name has been revealed.
Stranger Than Heaven, the brand new title.
That looks interesting.
From RGG Studio.
This time, it's now 1943, and knowing RGG, I'm sure more surprises are surely on their way.
All right, well, we're almost done here, but we do have one final, very special global game announcement to share with all of you.
Oh, it's a global game announcement, guys.
Projects from teams around the world, including many brand new studios, were proud of that.
Guys, it says global game announcement.
SilkSong has already been announced.
It is no stranger to delivering blockbuster games time and again.
SilkSong is global!
I was absolutely blown away by the scale, scope, and ambition of this developer's vision.
While there are many places, really any place, this game could have been revealed, we are so deeply honored.
that we get to share it with the world right here, at Summer Game Fest.
Guys, guys, you think this is SilkSong?
Guys, do you think this is SilkSong?
Guys, look, when he said global announcement, I was like, guys, SilkSong has already been announced.
I don't think it's SilkSong.
SilkSong remastered.
Alternate universe SilkSong where they're all, what if they're like working in an office?
Is that it?
What if they're all just working in the office in this alternate universe?
SilkSong on Unreal Engine.
Hushed complain, yikes.
Please, we have to go.
Guys, remember Deadpool killed off SilkSong we could have had it?
And it was Deadpool killed off SilkSong.
We could have d-d-d it was Deadpool killed off SilkSong to announce a fucking BR game.
If this is about the report you asked for yesterday, it'll be ready in three.
No, no, two days, tops.
Put a hold on that for now.
We found another body.
One that exhibits the same pathology as the others we've been investigating.
Dookie, stop dragging the joke into the mug.
That sounds like a fan that's so tired of waiting for Celsock.
He's so tired.
The Renwood Hotel.
Oh.
I know.
That's where your mother was murdered.
What the fuck?
Alyssa died eight years ago.
Perhaps it's time for you to face the past.
Is this Evil Within?
Grace.
But they said it was a small dev team?
Or not a small dev team, but, like, not, like, a well-known dev team.
No, it's not Resident Evil, because they said just wait.
Wait and we'll announce it one day.
Oh, this is the one that I've been searching for.
The special one.
The chosen one.
Miss Ashcroft.
Oh, this is a new IP.
We need to keep our voices down.
Have you seen the same shit I've seen?
Please know that you are my hope.
Everyone's gone.
Wait.
What?
Wait!
Is this Resident Evil?
Re...
Oh!
They were, like, the small studio.
We'll also be hosting opening night live on Tuesday, August 19th.
These fuckers were, like, this small studio.
I can't believe they chose us.
It's just about survival horror.
Expect high-stakes cinematic action, too, with much more to share soon, leading up to its launch on February 27th, 2026.
Holy shit!
That's so soon!
That's half a year!
That was an amazing announcement.
Oh, my God!
The small dev team known as Capcom.
Let's thank our co-host, Lucy James.
Didn't you do a great job, everyone?
I'd play Resident Evil.
Resident Evil's not as scary as Silent Hill.
Resident Evil is more a shooty-shooty.
I can't believe it for the first time.
I know!
I can't believe it!
They're like, we don't need you, Bible!
All right, well, there's much more Summer Game Fest to come.
Make sure to visit SummerGameFest.com to see a listing of all the digital events this weekend.
You can watch and highlight even more games, including the Xbox Game Showcase on Sunday.
And stay tuned online to see coverage of many of the playable games at Summer Game Fest Play Days that's taking place this weekend in L.A.
And make sure to stay tuned for Day of the Devs, which is coming up next with additional new reveals from incredible independent studios around the world.
I can't believe they baited us three times.
They're like, we'll have the announcement soon.
I just hope we can wait a little longer.
And then they're like, JK, by waiting a little longer, I mean, wait 30 minutes.
I can't believe it!
They actually baited us.
Soon is now.
Like, what the fuck?
I did not expect that at all.
Yeah.
Holy fuck.
And then when he was like, small in the dev team.
Like, of course I didn't expect...
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
That was loud.
Sorry.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Okay, ouch.
Yeah.
That...
Yeah, no.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I don't know.
Okay, sorry.
That was from the stream itself.
Everyone was freaking out and being like, what the fuck?
Why was it so loud?
Yeah.
I know.
I was like, holy fuck instantly.
Yeah, everyone in the Twitch chat, in the actual episode podcast, was like, what the fuck?
Um, um, but yeah, like, they actually baited us.
I can't believe that was the, oh my God.
Even Jeff was like, small in the dev team.
And I was just like, wow, okay.
What, what game would it be then?
Like,
oh my God.
But yeah, for those of you wondering why I never played, I talked about this before a long time ago, but I know, like, I remember I even said it before in the past, but like, the reason why I couldn't stream Resident Evil games was because you need a Japanese copy to play the game because it would,
um, because it had the censored version of, because it's censored in Japan with like, the blood splatters and everything.
So I was never able to actually play Resident Evil because of it.
Because, um, other people were able to stream it back then.
The ones who were able to stream it literally had the Japanese copy of the game.
Like, they had a Japanese account, Steam account, so they could buy the JP.
So we weren't allowed to stream back then when I had to get perms and stuff.
We weren't allowed to, like, stream the game Unless it's the Japanese copy.
Because we can't play the NA copy.
Because it didn't have the right censorship or anything.
Like the blood censors and stuff.
Because it's less gory in the JP version for Resident Evil.
So, yeah.
I explained that before.
Because I remember you guys in the past were like, Oh, why don't you stream the Resident Evil games?
And I was like, I can't.
I have an NA Steam account.
I don't have a JP account.
But now I can.
Now I can.
I've always wanted to play the newer Resident Evil games.
I don't know about...
The reason why I never played Village or the other Resident Evil 7 or 8.
Was because I watched so much gameplay of 7 and 8.
That I just feel like it's not special to me.
Because I really, really liked Resident Evil the franchise.
And because of that, I watched so much of the gameplay.
And I don't like playing a game where I've already watched the gameplay of already.
And, like, know what's going on.
And know, like, everything about the lore.
And everything.
So, I already got so much exposure to the game itself.
That's why I never actually streamed it now.
But I wanted to stream it on launch.
When it first launched.
And, like, when I had less exposure.
But when I found out back then when I couldn't stream it.
I just, like, read everything about it.
Watched everything about the gameplay.
So, like, it wasn't that special to me at that point.
But, like, I would love to stream Resident Evil 9.
I'm looking forward to it.
It seems really, really, really fun.
But, yeah.
A lot of games I'm looking forward to.
The Sonic Racing.
The Sonic Racing game.
I'm looking forward to that.
Resident Evil 9.
That's, yeah.
The Sonic Racing with Hatsune Miku.
And Steve.
What was the other one?
There was a second game where I was like, oh, my God.
The Muppet Boxing.
Yes.
Okay.
The Muppet Boxing.
Sonic Racing.
And Resident Evil 9.
Those were the three games I was most looking for.
Oh, and the Souls-like game.
The Chinese Souls-like game.
But, like, that one wasn't a global announcement.
So, I wasn't, like, you know, oh, yeah.
Like, super...
That one I already knew about it for a while.
And also the new Onimusha.
Because they already announced those two games already.
The other three games that were just...
I meant the games that were just announced from there.
I already knew about the Onimusha game.
And I already knew about the Chinese Souls-like game for a while.
So, like, I'm looking forward to those two games, but they're not like... I'm looking forward to those two games as well, but it's not like, oh, they're new, that I just found out about it.
But yeah, that was really fun.
Really long showcase.
I feel like they were never this long before.
Was that me?
This seems really, really long.
I was not expecting how long it was.
Yeah.
Like, I feel like usually it's like an hour or an hour and a half, but two hours... it was a two-hour show.
This year was a lot.
But I felt like I didn't see a lot of trailers that I want to play.
For me, there wasn't really a lot of trailers where I was like, oh, yeah, I want to play that.
It was a long, long one.
I did get a little bored midway because it felt like it did drag on a little bit.
But there were some good announcements.
I always love doing these watch-alongs with you guys to see what the new games are.
But thank y'all for coming.
I do have another stream later tonight in an hour because I didn't think I was going to, you know, I thought I had more break in between, but this was a two-hour showcase.
But I have another stream later in an hour on YouTube.
For those who are new here, my name is DokiBird.
My mic sounds weird because I'm traveling right now, but I'll be back tomorrow with my usual setup, so everything's going to be good from there.
But please check me out on YouTube.
If you want to see me on other...
If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, check me out on Twitter.
Follow me there, exclamation point Twitter, exclamation point social media, exclamation point YouTube.
Check me over all those platforms.
If you want to support me via other means, I do have my merch.
I have my merch, I have my Hyatt cases, custom PC cases, and I have my gamer subcode.
So there's another way to check me out there.
And also, thank you again for all the bitties, for all the support, for all the follows, for all the raids.
I really appreciate it.
I appreciate watching this with you guys.
It's always fun seeing the new stuff.
Hey guys, I'm going to head off now.
There's no raids because I have one monitor, so I really don't want to...
Like, I always... I want to be careful with where I'm going when I have one monitor, because I'm like only sharing one screen.
Oh...
So there won't be a raid.
You can just disperse wherever you want to go.
But anyway guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!